I haven't watched it so I don't know
wash light I'm people vs. oj what
American crime story Sarah Paulson
snagged an Emmy and a Golden Globe for
her portrayal of Marcia Clark and the
People vs oj simpson we hope this
verdict does not discourage the victims
who were out there but she told Stephen
Colbert she still hasn't watched it on
Mondays The Late Show and here's life
I've seen everybody else's work who's
been nominated I think it's easier to
sit in your chair if you're clapping for
someone else if you don't know what you
did cuz I could have been really I could
have been super stinky Amelie oh yeah
that girl she totally deserves it it's
easier to just you know so I haven't
watched it I'm protecting myself from
the trauma that is losing I'm so ashamed
the 42 year olds actress does do this
though yeah actually travel with your
Marcia Clark wig everywhere you go I
take it with me to a hotel rooms before
I get ready for these events cuz I it's
just a way of communing with the thing
that had been so great yeah yeah which
was wearing this thing a halt on my head
you